aber es gibt eine Grenze in der Tat und
die sind wo ist diese ich sag mal bei
Phosphor und streubom wir haben klare
wir haben und wir sind unterzeichnet der
entsprechenden internationalen
Konventionen wir produzieren sie nicht
mehr wir halten sie nicht mehr vor und
wir haben versprochen vertraglich
unterzeichnet dass wir sie nicht mehr
einsetzen das heißt wenn die Russen das
machen würden trotzdem nicht weil so
argumentieren ja die Ukraine und sagen
das machen die auch wir brauchen das
auch ja aber wir haben eine klare Linie
in all diesen völkerrechtlichen Fragen
dass wir immer sagen das rechte
stärkeren darf nicht das Recht brechen
und dazu gehört auch dass wir uns unsere
eigenen Regeln halten und die Regel
heißt der hatte Waffen setzen wir nicht
ein jetzt reden alle über Kampfjets die
können eine Rolle spielen da können wir
uns aber jetzt als Deutschland so sehr
wie wir im Fokus standen bei den Panzern
wegen Leopard Hersteller Nation können
wir uns jetzt ein bisschen zurücklehnen
weil es um jetzt geht die wir gar nicht
haben
[Musik]